why i use
both google drive and dropbox so i got a
tweet from one of my followers uh
wayne who wrote in the say quick
question evan why
both dropbox and google drive when you
can have most of the similar features on
drive
so here's the thing okay i love both
services
dropbox i started first and dropbox i
use for a number of reasons first of all
it's my hard drive so all of my main
files are saved to my dropbox
so it provides me with backup so if i
ever
lose anything i can always find it i
have a computer
at my office and a laptop at home and my
files are automatically synced in
between them
so if i update something at the office
it's automatically on my computer at
home
and if you ever want to install a new
computer all i have to do is download
dropbox
leave it to run overnight and all my
files are instantly there so it's
amazing
and again i guess if i'm working
remotely from somebody else's computer i
can always get access to my files
so i love dropbox i've had my whole team
on it
we share files we share folders uh so if
they update it
and automatically update it on my
computer it's just a fantastic way to
share files
and update them and work on projects
together the problem i started facing
why i started using google drive
was the videos
these videos these videos were killing
my dropbox so when i make these videos
sometimes it's as much as 20 gigabytes
it's a ton of videos i got a new camera
it's higher resolution i make 14 videos
typically in one sitting
so it's a lot of video content and what
was happening was
first of all i don't have a ton of space
on my mac air
it's flash drive doesn't have a ton of
space so i don't want
my videos on my laptop so what i would
do is i take my camera
i put them on my office computer which
has tons of space
download them there and then i share a
folder on drive with christine in my
video editor
so the files are only shared between my
office computer
and christina and it doesn't come to my
home
laptop which would suck up all the space
and suck up all my bandwidth
at home because the residential internet
is not as fast as my
commercial internet that is the main
reason why
i use google drive i like some of the uh
the file sharing so you can if you're
working on like a google drive document
the excel type of document spreadsheet
two people can edit at the same time
that's pretty cool but for the most part
i only use google drive to share my
video files which are huge
with christina and i use dropbox for
everything else
so there may be a way to do it within
dropbox if there is i haven't figured it
out
the one negative with drive is you can't
throttle the the speed so
if i'm at the office and i put my videos
on and they're going to christina
i have to do it overnight because
otherwise it just shuts down my internet
i can't do anything else except sync my
files with dropbox
you can set limits as to how much
bandwidth it takes up so you can still
do
your regular work your regular browsing
whatever you need to do
while it's being synced maybe that'll
get fixed hopefully they'll be get fixed
in
not too long there's a lot of people
complaining about it but that's why i
use both dropbox and google drive maybe
a little technical but
uh that's my answer anyways if you guys
like this video
please give it a thumbs up thanks for
the great question if you have a comment
or question leave it below in the
comments section
and subscribe to the channel if you want
to see more views like this thank you so
much
and i'll see you soon